peu
[Applaudissements]
des chances
les gens
les garagistes
les chansons en français
m
[Musique]
chat glouton prend sa possible
la note on pense à possible et s'en va
tromper les gens
les cent pas
mais
mais en chemin vert
un travailleur immigré
et on a en
louvier là
il y avait cinq ans
il est
qui
l'achat
moi j'ai trouvé
tant auprès de ma blonde
montferrand
près de ma blonde
[Musique]
elles sont alléchants
les chansons
chanter
[Musique]
petit navire
sur l'eau
petit coup c'est agréable
[Musique]
c'est beau mais là
ils vont déjà
comme elle a besoin
[Musique]
tout au long
trop
[Musique]
ne pleure pas janet de mari
ne pleure pas jeannette
vitesse
[Musique]
on entendait de danser ce soir
seconde
tandis que s'arrête nous on continue à
faire
[Musique]
on ignore
sur la tête
ainsi font font font les petites
marionnettes ainsi font font font trois
petits tours et puis s'en vont ainsi
qu'on confond trois petits tours et nous
partons
il
alléchant
j
dedans
pour toulon
[Musique]